[Música]
en directo vamos a Lima con nuestro
corresponsal Francisco Zacarías para
hablar sobre la investigación iniciada
por la fiscalía contra el ministro de
salud Jorge López por presunto
enriquecimiento ilícito en agravio del
Estado un caso que salpica aún más al
gobierno del presidente Pedro Castillo
solo un par de días atrás el mandatario
había anunciado la salida de López tras
una denuncia presentada en un medio de
comunicación Francisco Buenas noches
cuéntenos Cuál es el argumento de la
fiscalía para investigar al destituido
ministro de salud Jorge López
buenas noches para la fiscalía se
habrían cometido los delitos de lavado
de activos enriquecimiento ilícito luego
que la expareja de Jorge López habría
comprado con un departamento con dinero
que se supone sería de fuente ilícita
que fue depositado en una cuenta
corriente por trabajadores del
Ministerio de salud que dicho sea de
paso son personal de confianza de Jorge
López y también por una empresa médica
el juez Richard Concepción carhuancho ha
afirmado que el dinero sería de
procedencia ilícita y estaría vinculado
a actos de corrupción este escándalo
estalló la noche del domingo y han
transcurrido casi tres días y hasta el
momento el presidente Pedro Castillo no
ha emitido una resolución Suprema que
señale el retiro del puesto de Jorge
López esto ha dejado su eficacias para
muchos críticos del mandatario peruano y
ellos afirman que es por esa razón que
hasta el el gobierno de Pedro Castillo
se encuentra incompleto Y esa sería la
razón por la cual el gobernante no ha
podido hacer que sea oficialice el fin
del estado de emergencia por la pandemia
del Coby 19 que los ministros aprobaron
esta tarde Francisco ahora qué motivó a
los congresistas Aliados del presidente
Pedro Castillo a pedir al mandatario que
asuma su responsabilidad en la crisis
política y que cambie a sus ministros
Sí justamente un pronunciamiento
congresistas del grupo Perú democrático
señalaron que el gobierno de Pedro
Castillo tiene poca capacidad de gestión
y señalan que el mandatario ni nos
integrantes de su gabinete tienen algún
este motivo para dar pruebas de que
estarían alejándose de cualquier indicio
de corrupción y lo critican al
mandatario porque señalan que ha
nombrado ministros altos funcionarios
que al igual que sus familiares se
encuentran investigados
estaban ellos este prófugos de la
justicia o detenidos en algunos casos
por presunta corrupción esta situación
es un algo delicada para Pedro Castillo
porque precisamente entre otras cosas
Mañana una corte va a decidir si aprueba
o rechaza el pedido una acusación
constitucional que ha hecho la fiscal
general de Perú contra el manda peruano
ante el El Congreso de esta nación Y si
la tutela derecho que ha sido
interpuesta por la defensa de Pedro
Castillo es aprobada esto le daría un
respaldo al mandatario para bloquear
cualquier tipo de proceso que intenten
realizar tanto el legislativo como el
Ministerio Público la suerte de Pedro
Castillo está en manos del juez Juan
Carlos checkley